Your accent is very sexual.
Is it a mix of things?
Is it Australian-Asian?
Do you know what?
I don't even feel
like I have an accent.
I feel like you're the
one with the accent.
I'm aware I sound like
a talking sewer cap.
I'm aware of that, I just wanted
to know where your accent,
what it is.
Malaysian, Singapore.
Singapore is a good
place, I like Singapore.
Isn't Singapore like if
you throw gum on floor,
they'll beat your
ass with bamboo?
They will cane you.
They'll cane you with
(bleep) panda food.
How weird is that?
Yeah, that is pretty weird.
But also, if you
throw gum on the floor
in any New Yorkers home,
they'll beat the (bleep) out
of you as well, so I mean.
Oh yeah, yeah.
In Singapore we
do the same thing,
we just outsource the
ass-kicking to the government.
Welcome to Stupid Questions
with Chris Distefano.
I'm Chris Distefano.
This is Ronny Chieng
from the Daily Show,
and he's also got his show
Ronny Chieng:
International Student,
coming out on the Comedy
Central app August 13th.
August 13th, it's a
good day, good day.
Good day.
Good day, that's iced tea.
Aren't you like a huge
star in Australia?
I guess I am.
Well here's the
first stupid question,
do you think Australia is
too far and Jesus hates it?
I think it is too far, and
I think Jesus hates it, yes.
Yeah, is that why you think
he pushed it all the way.
How does Australia work, again?
It's so far we
can't, first of all,
isn't it like 10
years from now there?
Yeah, yeah.
It's not the same time.
Not the same
time frame at all,
right there Kennedy
is still president.
Yeah.
I gotta tell you
'bout that ending,
it comes to brutal,
tell your people.
Well they don't know yet,
so don't tell Australia.
Yeah, it's a shocker.
What's your favorite
state capital?
State capital?
State capital.
Or for you, you know, 'cause
International Student,
I'll allow this just for today,
what's your favorite
international capital?
I'm a big capital
guy, Chrisy capitals.
Is Honolulu a capital?
That is the capital of Hawaii.
Yeah.
You ever been out there?
I've been out there
twice, love it, love Hawaii.
It's like what would happen if
Asian people were in charge.
There you go, you picked
the most Asian capital.
Other than Asia, obviously.
Yeah.
Hawaii's awesome,
great weather.
As soon as you land it
smells like flowers.
Right.
Everyone's polite,
there's beaches.
Yeah.
Food is great.
I'm a big Pierre,
South Dakota, guy.
Have you been to Pierre?
I've never been, no.
I've really never been
outside New Jersey.
This question is really
dumb, just answer.
Do you watch porn anymore?
I never stopped, really.
Right, never stopped.
It's a continuous
thing that I'm, you know,
in between this I'm probably
going to go watch some porn.
I've been going thoughts
lately, just all thoughts.
Oh, just memory?
Well not even memory,
sometimes I just
kind of get in a zone
where my mind is blank,
and then I just jizz.
Oh, right.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's one way to do it.
It's a type of meditating.
That's very zen,
that's a zen orgasm.
I started the
transcendental meditation.
Yeah.
And then I notice
I'm getting in this,
you know, I'm 10, 15 minutes
in, I have a full boner.
And then next thing you
know I need a napkin.
I don't know what it is.
No, that's not
transcendental meditation.
That's not?
That's something else.
That's glory holes?
I don't think enlightenment
ends with an orgasm.
But how great would it be?
It should though.
Alright, here's a dumb question.
Tell me about your underwear.
Thank you for asking.
Yes, what do you
got on right now?
Dude, I've gone
through several
iterations of this process.
Okay.
First of all, good
underwear, so important.
Absolutely.
Underrated.
Yes.
Shitty underwear
ruins your life.
Absolutely.
And people don't even know
they have shitty underwear
because they're so used to
wearing shitty underwear
they think that's normal!
Right.
That pain isn't normal.
You shouldn't feel pain.
Right.
One time I thought I
had testicular cancer,
but it was just I was
wearing the wrong underwear.
Yeah!
That's all it was,
they were nut huggers.
Now, my whole
thing, long underwear.
Wow, old school?
I'm talking almost to your
knees, almost to your knees.
Wow, like a 1920 bathing suit.
Yeah, that's exactly it.
Holy crap.
Because guess what?
When you get that long
underwear, it never rides up.
Yeah, and I've
seen, you're hung too.
I'm all the way,
I'm hung and my underwear
is long all the way down.
I'm wearing underwear
to my ankles.
Alright Ron, did
you have a good time?
Mm-hmm.
You really did?
Yeah, sure.
Appreciate it, man.
I want to give you a gift.
Stupid questions, you
get a stupid gift.
That's very thoughtful
of you, thank you so much.
So you're a guy,
you sell socks on your
website ronnychieng.com.
Yup.
So I wanted to give you socks
with my face and
name on it backwards
because I didn't realize
that when you send it
to the sock company,
they reverse the image.
So it's my face, but it's
my name is backwards.
These are something.
Absolutely, yeah.
And I got my face right there.
Also did you get these
in size 12, what is this?
Yeah.
And then you got your socks
with your face on it, right?
[Ronny] Yeah.
Why don't you show us your
socks and that flexibility?
Thank God I got
master flexibility.
[Chris] Could you?
No don't, you
might hurt yourself.
I should send you
some of my socks.
That's why I kind of did it,
if I'm being honest with you,
I didn't do it for you, I
did it kind of cross for me.
So I'd appreciate some socks.
[Ronny] No problem, man.
Now put that leg down.
Feel free to put those socks
on your little baby Asian
feet whenever you want.